please make the heading and before we
get stuck into literally the nuts and
bolts of these arm trigonometric
expansions whatever that means you need
to know why you're doing this you've got
to have a purpose because otherwise
you're just shuffling around symbols and
it's like what was this even for okay so
I'm gonna give you two reasons the first
reason just overall is calculus now I
need to explain that because that's very
broad it's like why is that because
calculus so let me try and unpack this
for you let's think and this is not a
rhetorical question I actually want you
to help me out with this let's think
what kinds of things do we know how to
do with calculus alone because we've
been in this for a while now you can do
heaps of stuff go right back to the
start right guys it's that what was the
very first thing you learn to do
differentiate right and you said okay
well this is all about the gradient
function yes so we we unpack that we
looked at the geometry of the curve
stationary points points inflection etc
right you learn to differentiate what
kinds of functions did we start off love
it to integrate sorry differentiate we
get to integration a minute what kinds
of functions we looked at linear
functions we looked at quadratics we
looked at Q anything basically where
it's a polynomial yeah so we looked at
polynomial functions because they were
nice and neat and the rule for
differentiating them is really easy to
learn okay
also it sort of fit with first
principles you remember we introduced
first principles limits and all that
kind of thing so we learned how to deal
with these and then we also learnt what
happens when you combine them so for
example if you've got a polynomial
divided by another polynomial and you're
like I don't know what to do with this
how do you yeah we did that rules for
this right so that was the question rule
that we were just referring to there but
that wasn't the only rule what other
ones the chain rule very good and if
instead of dividing you multiply
functions what would you do you use the
product rule right so so this is all
under the heading of differentiation
really then we learned how to undo
differentiation what's that called
integration we already said it a couple
today by accident we learnt how to do
integration and then after we sort of
covered that we're like well we know how
to do lots of things now we're kind of
running out of space in in polynomial
land so we learnt how to deal with a
whole different family of functions
right do you remember what was earlier
this term what to introduce logs and
Exponential's so I'm putting that up
here because you learn how to do all of
these other things
differentiation quotient chain product
and iteration you've learned how to do
them with logs and Exponential's as well
okay so what we're coming to now is well
now where do we go where do we take this
this knowledge or where do we take these
skills and it's really only one kind of
family of functions left that we haven't
touched yet and you've been working with
them for years so it's kind of weird
that we've waited this long what's
missing and the answer is geometry right
we haven't looked at sign or cars or tan
in this context at all we're still
thinking about it with triangles and
with graphs that you've been doing very
recently okay
but we don't know how to do any calculus
with them yet which kind of leads to the
next thing how did we um I haven't
written it here but how do we first deal
with these polynomials and develop the
laws we looked at first principles right
now underneath this little spot here I'm
actually gonna have to need a new arrow
I need first principles let's just write
down what is first principle what's the
actual there's a formula for it right if
you've got a function if then the
derivative of that function equals a
we'd limit thing what was the limit the
limit of as H approaches you're very
good and then there was a fraction what
was the fraction yeah f of X plus h
minus f of X all divided by H there we
go now if you're struggling to remember
that it has been a little while so
that's okay but just remember all it is
is rise over run rise over run yeah and
where we're thinking about what happens
when the run gets really really tiny
because they're not interested in
sequence we're interested in tangents as
if the run was like well as if the run
is nothing okay so if this is what first
principles look like
what would happen if we apply this idea
to trigonometry out of all the
trigonometric trigonometric functions
you know which is the most basic one
it's sign right so if I said the
derivative of sine well if I try to
tackle that with just this first
principles at all right I would say the
limit as H approaches zero of what well
yeah the the function I'm interested in
differentiating is sine so instead of
writing f of X plus h I will write sine
of X plus h you with me that's just the
particular f that I'm looking at -
what's on the engine you just sine X and
then you're dividing by H because you're
always divided by H okay now at this
moment you can see aha now we've we've
sort of crossed into an area where we
don't we don't have the knowledge to
deal with this object because this guy
here you're like well I don't know what
that is
now it's very tempting to think that
that might be equal to this it's super
tempting and students make this error
all the time okay now it's tempting to
think that cuz like expanding brackets
sometimes does that but you have at
least two significant pieces of
knowledge that tell you this cannot be
this have a think trigonometric
expansions are not the only kinds of
expansions you've dealt with in this
course I want you to think all the way
back to term one last year what kinds of
expansions did you deal with there was a
whole topic about it think think think
back I think it was very close to
algebra it was an extension one topic
and we've chucked it into your AP ones
it was the expansion it's not a trig but
of you know binomials
for instance yeah do you remember this
okay now we spent a whole topic on this
introduce Sigma notation and norm
Pascal's triangle and all that just to
show that this is not as simple this
just saying this right in fact that's
not true for any value of whatever that
thing up in there whatever that power is
right so number one piece of information
that makes us suspicious that when you
spending these brackets it doesn't just
turn to something neat and simple like
that but there's one other reason you
can really obvious like a year 10 almost
there 9 reason why you can know that
this is not true sign 9 degrees don't
say it out but you know what this is
equal to right you know where that value
in fact it's one of the first ones that
you learn okay well let me think about
breaking that 90 degrees into two pieces
what if I were to break it into two
pieces for instance I could say break it
into sine 30 and sine 60 right 30 plus
60 is 90 yeah but what are these things
equal to what is same no - you can tell
me now it's one what's a sine 30 it's a
half but sine 60 it doesn't work does it
because what is sine 60 it's root 3 on 2
so when you add these together you
clearly do not get this right even
though 30 and 60 do add to 90 okay
so sine X plus h is not just going to
equal to these things independently so
we have to work out what to do with
these things
okay so when we master this skill when
we do work out what this is equal to you
will find it's useful for all kinds of
things not just calculus but the reason
we're meeting it now is because you need
it for calculus that's where we're up to
does that make sense
ok so I'm going to take Anna Jenny
we're going to work out with theses